aurélie rivers a fait son chemin mais
avec une seule main cet handicap l'a
forcé à se dépasser a rarement se
laisser devancer aujourd'hui trois de
mes quatre noms sont des rapports si je
bois et mes meilleurs temps des deux
manches brodeur votre monde si je
voulais leur mêlée leur servent de
support à 20 3 1 ce bonheur d'être
champion du monde plusieurs fois
or il dit le partage avec sa jumelle
charlotte à saint jean sur richelieu où
elles ont grandi l'essor rivard sont
toutes les deux des stars
je me fais arrêter dans la rue des fois
félicitations pour vos médailles puis
moi je dis merci
mais toutes ces médailles la nageuse
paralympique par excellence au monde les
a acquises après une lutte acharnée
contre elle-même il y a dix ans aurélie
avait peur de sauter à l'eau est
accroché à un poteau par les deux corps
je me tirais challenge et moi je voulais
pas parce qu'elles ne seront pas tu
avais pas de quoi avoir peur de se voir
aurélie à cet âge là était la victime
parfaite que l'estimé de soi était pas
son plein potentiel
si j'étais sur le banc l'abc non pas
dans les estrades fallait tout choquée
de voir si je ne voyais pas et j'ai
paniqué cette anxiété qui la rendait si
fragile a mené relie à se replier sur
elle-même et à vivre une année entière
d'intimidation lors de son transfert
dans une nouvelle école secondaire sport
études
jamais je pense à cacher ma main puis je
pense à générer beaucoup d'insécurité
j'ai commencé à répondre aux gens d'en
face
j'avais crié en quatre ans d'émotions a
dans sa phase mais ça avait marché
ouvert à la vérité aujourd'hui ses clips
détresse sont loin derrière elle pouvoir
vivre seul est un accomplissement et ne
pas avoir de main gauche semble le
dernier de ses soucis au tapis une
prothèse protège oui mais plus
esthétique plus que je pensais
deux fois par semaine aurait 10 sera à
l'université de montréal où elle prépare
tranquillement son après carrière
m
c'est comme je me vois pas dans l'autre
sens
une fois en classe
la championne du monde passent inaperçus
ses collègues n'ont aucune idée de qui
est laid est-ce que tu savais que
j'aurais little champion du monde non
pas du tout vraiment pas du tout je suis
désolé chez des vivres à saint jean sur
richelieu une rare visite d'aurélie est
toujours une occasion de se réjouir
après tout son succès et une réussite
familiale
c'est ce que savourer ce titre est un
peu anxieuse mais maintenant le des
outils et des moyens de les gérer
mais elle peut dire qu'à la fin des
produits vraiment j'en fasse au poirier
radio-canada mûri
[Musique]